[Music]
all right and we are live a dizzy boy
Lord I'm Jay also known as MJ's a boss
we are back at it again with another
review video for the ion wars podcast
Dream Team today we're gonna be talking
about layers of fear - and this game was
made by Gunn media and I would like to
thank Gunn media for sending me the code
in giving him - cockney little Cognito
hooking your brother up once I first
started this I did not play the first
game at all
who knows this game ii was pretty creepy
I don't really know anything about it
because once I saw the thing that they
posted I've heard good things about it
but I don't know it's just like it just
looked kind of creepy it gave me creepy
vibes so once I first started in the
game I walk I start walking around on
this boat and then I see Mir sitting
there and then I pick it up and turn it
around to see like the actual mir part
for the reflection see what my character
looked like and it made like a loud loud
noise and it scared the hell out of me I
you know I was not prepared for that and
there was like multiple jump scares
which I really really liked about the
game like one thing about me is I really
really like scary games like um Resident
Evil biohazard the remake of Resident
Evil 2 I really really liked those games
the evil within series my it's one of my
favorite favorite games of all time both
of those but this game it was it was
pretty good I really liked sneaking
around on the boat and then later along
you start seeing like cameras following
you it's like they're making a movie out
of your movements which I thought was
pretty cool I mean like seeing that I
don't know he's just like
there was a lot of jump-scares too and
it was very unusual but it was a really
really good unusual like big there's a
part with a pirate ship or once you'd
like spin the wheel there's waves that
would start moving which I thought that
was pretty cool
um what else what else what else the
collectibles are movie posters and I
thought that was pretty cool
but I don't know it's just like the game
was creepy which is a good thing because
I really really like scary demons like I
said earlier but in the layers of fear -
there wasn't really an enemy that I saw
except for the thing with the mirror I
couldn't tell if that was like the main
person of the game it froze myself and
it just made a lot of noise to scare me
but so far as of what I played during
this video that you guys are about to
see I didn't really get to like see an
enemy I mean there's like a bunch of
mannequins and hear noises from behind
you it got said the sound quality for
this game is insane and the graphics - I
mean the graphics are pretty good I mean
not gonna lie I mean they were pretty
good especially for a scary game cuz you
look at names like the evil within the
first one the graphics I mean for that
back in that time the graphics were good
back at that time but nowadays if you
compare them it's like but layers of
fear - mmhmm that's what it's about but
yeah it's like there's cameras following
you around the entire game and it's like
they're filming a movie about you but
it's like everything is set up to happen
like they want you to activate switches
to make a little circle thing move and
then you have to press a button to line
up a chair to drop down at a certain
part if you can you guys will see it
farther along in the video but but yeah
it did you boy Lord I'm Jay and that is
my thoughts and my impressions of my
little review about layers of fear - and
yeah thank you guys and pee
submerged tightly surrounded by lives
and yes he stands on a stage where every
man must play a part is a sad one
all right let's get right into it so far
it's a pretty interesting game kind of
interesting
I could say
I haven't seen any enemies which I'm
happy about so far like any scary things
because hell
I don't want to see who it is mm-hmm
nope
like this
my god wake up Donny I've got to get out
of this godforsaken prison before we
bust they just tried to kill me that get
out of here
shoot what the hell
is there a certain number than I need
hello
what's the second anything doesn't say
anything just say anything
oh boy guys I think I'm locked in here
but the thing is I don't know the
combination Oh 69
oh [ __ ] don't want to be in this next
room
Elena
see that little camera is looking at me
[Music]
oh okay so I think I need to like right
I need to kill him I think we're I need
to place her okay okay so I think I'm
building the scene of the thing
Oh turn that down a little bit put a
damper to the front of them go yeah I'll
have to wait them for this thing go all
the way around all over again you suck
I'm slow
all right it's close it's good
alright let's do this [ __ ] okay put that
right there pop
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get the hell out of there get the hell
out of there
go this way
[Music]
just block my way
you